[Applause]
[Music]
happy wednesday night before
thanksgiving oh do we have a great panel
tonight dr mark siegel is here
yeah
he's the only guest who lets us borrow
his prescription pad there you go
and here's tom chalu he's so
there he is wow
he's so white he thinks marshmallows are
too spicy
we got degan mcdowell in the studio
if she hears one more southern
stereotype she'll beat you to death with
a possum
and finally there's jimmy fayla
voted one of america's best dressed men
by used car salesman magazine
all right to the monologue so while
citizens grapple with an insane crime
wave what are the most enlightened
concerned with language yes as the deeds
get worse they believe it's the words
that must change not the behavior for
example we've seen lots of looting this
week but you know what's worse
calling it looting
looting is a term that we typically
use when people of color or urban
dwellers are doing something we tend not
to use that term for other people when
they do the exact same thing
so wait color dictates the language
and who defined that for us joy reid
so if white people do it do we call it
something else i'd say white collar
crime but it hardly takes a phd in
finance to smash the window of a cvs and
grab 150 men in speed sticks
i got a lot for that
and why are we trying to protect white
looters feelings maybe they're just poor
white people who needed dozens of
expensive handbags to survive
but i guess if we find out they're black
then it's back to looters
meanwhile the organized media still
calls the intentional massacre in
wisconsin a deadly parade crash as if a
mickey mouse hot air balloon collided
with a power line
that would be the best thing disney's
made in years
but the media has a conflict of interest
they stoked racial tensions with lies
about kyle rittenhouse in the same state
this massacre took place in that makes
it less intentional homicide and more an
act of god but if that car crash were an
accident it qualifies as the longest
accidental car crash in history and the
911 hijackers accidentally slammed those
planes into those buildings
maybe it's an act of nature
and not mother nature because
that's sexist
it's nature born from inequality caused
by systemic racism
but it's not just words it's also
numbers here's a fantastic tweet from
the women's march quote
we apologize deeply for the email that
was sent today
14.92 cents was our average donation
amount this week it was an oversight on
our part to not make the connection to a
year of colonization conquest and
genocide for indigenous people
especially before thanksgiving
but it just proves what we've been
saying all along math is racist
these woke nuts are more sensitive than
my nipples after a marathon
they like the nipple jokes tom but just
wait
a few more weeks in 1492 will be the
price of gas
but imagine being so self-centered you
think numbers are out to get you
[Music]
well mr king welcome to the company
we're eager to get you started i
understand there was some trouble with
your employee id badge number uh we've
prepared a few options for you what do
you think of this one
69 that is sexual harassment sir oh well
the numbers are randomly generated uh
maybe this one
420 hitler's birthday i am triggered
okay um ooh
i know you'll appreciate this one number
58008
that is my favorite number
upside down
we knew you'd appreciate that one
welcome to teen vogue
[Music]
now
the women's march tweet was funny in an
unintentional way when feminists are
funny it's usually by accident a sexist
would say
it's not unlike the wisconsin massacre
or as cnn calls it a deadly parade
incident like somebody accidentally fell
to their death from the top of the tom
turkey float
incident that's so careful that's the
vegas definition of terrorism since
ilhan omar described 911 as some people
did something imagine if cnn were this
careful with other crap but with the
police the pee tape covington or
cavanaugh they jump right in but here
they pull back why is that maybe they're
just tired of paying nick sandman
or could it be about race when cnn
declares that the most dangerous thing
alive is an angry white man this story
won't fit but the best take of all comes
from this zero shane firo who said quote
what if instead of asking whether a tiny
bit more jail would have fixed this
person we asked whether fewer cars
suvs in america would lead to fewer
people killed
so firo's literally literally implying
people don't kill people cars kill
people
this person belongs in the morons hall
of fame
otherwise known as the view
[Laughter]
so i guess we need we need car control
now just to bring the homicide rate down
by the way pharaoh is part of a union
that wants to end cash bail and even if
their policies lead to death they just
cling harder to their deadlier beliefs
so it wasn't daryl brooks's fault it was
the gas guzzling suv's fault hell ford
named it the
escape true
meanwhile colorado is changing the way
sex offenders are labeled what's the new
label gonna tell you how many calories
you burn chasing a fifth grader back to
her house
the sex offender management board wants
to change the term sex offender to
something less stigmatizing saying
labels based on traits people can't
control is bad
so wait a second they're gonna have to
change the name of their own board it's
the sex offenders board
yeah cause sex offenders are just
victims of their own uncontrollable
behavior
geez i hope they find another name for
subway flasher just so jimmy feels
better
i recognize that face
and that birthmark anywhere
that's one sex offender referring to me
by a label for something i did half my
life ago is inappropriate and downright
offensive which might be the exact words
his victim used to describe his behavior
the creep added that client would be a
better term which is a great idea then
start a sex offenders club for men and
make a commercial where you say i'm not
just the president but also a client
one public defender agrees saying it
takes into consideration the uniqueness
of who's receiving treatment because the
last thing you want to do is lump a
child rapist in with a bunch of other
child rapists they're all as unique as
snowflakes
they chose the phrase adults who commit
sexual offenses i guess because cuomo
was already taken
my thinking these people don't want
survive society to survive ruining the
country is their path to remaking the
country as people die they play with
language and they play to win and the
necessary cost of their victory as one
wisconsin d.a once admitted is your
demise or shall i say unfortunate
incident and you can't go home and cry
to your mother because she's now called
a birthing person
[Applause]
[Music]
she's the only vegan who won't ruin
thanksgiving dinner boss business
everyday
his wardrobe wipes clean with a damp rag
[ __ ] across americorps jimmy fella
and he's only here to check out my rash
fox's contributor nyu medical process dr
mark stegall
and he's so white he thought the
pilgrims were too ethnic foxy's
contributor tom salud
jimmy i see you bought your you brought
your z jacket i hope you brought your a
game
that was the worst thing i've ever said
it was solid
you know i've been trying to think of a
way to call a truce in this little
wardrobe battle it's never gonna end i
know and i thought i had a solution i
was gonna take you to six flags and then
i realized you can't get on any of the
rides
back to the drawing board jimbo you know
i love the of this brilliant monologue
that i wrote
what
what part of it would you like to
address
the tweet from the women's march the
mutation of language how i eloquently
surmise the destruction of society well
i mean here's the truth we're going to
get into this on a serious note
we're in a really dangerous place right
now because we have more empathy for the
criminal than we do for the perp right
when you see the language get rewarded
we're more concerned with what hurt
feelings than actual hurt people i mean
imagine you're debating the semantics of
looting so you're in a store a guy comes
in swinging a crowbar right breaking
stuff you call 9-1-1 you're like hey
they're looting my store and the
operator is like well i wouldn't say
looting yes
was there a natural disaster recently
because you wouldn't quite constantly
you're like could you just send a cop
you know what i mean so that's the part
that scares me because we have to
inhabit this world most of the people
doing the reconfiguring don't that's
true um and when it comes to the women's
march i mean that's just hilarious like
they're so pandering and woke i'm
surprised they call themselves women at
this point
that's sexist yeah there's a little
sexist you know i don't see gender i'm a
little upset about this yeah yeah and
again the gripe with columbus is what he
killed adults i mean if he would have
killed babies the women's march would
have been like come on down
dirt bags that is an edgy hot take
i don't know shalou can you do better
than that
by the way
you do look like the world's scariest
irs agent he does he does
you have this
you have this like kind of like
appealing uh bland vanilla face
but it also is like a great white shark
right
it's like a great white it's like you're
coming at me and then you're just gonna
eat me alive well why don't we talk
about those deductions
[Laughter]
you know i was looking for i always look
for places where i can agree with these
weirdos you know and i found some common
ground on the sex offender thing i don't
think they should be called sex
offenders
but i think they should be called
something worse sex offender is already
i think a politically correct term
really yes it should be something well
you'd be more specific i want people to
be called the crimes they committed so
if you rape someone you're a rapist
right and if you look in people's
windows you're peeping tom i love that
term expose yourself you're a flashback
you're is tom no i know
but that's the thing i mean when i was a
kid that we used these terms and they
helped you make informed choices you
know you'd be like well i'm okay i'm
coming home from the playground i got to
cut through somebody's yard okay no that
guy's a rapist um no that guy's a
flasher that guy chases kids with
shovels i'm gonna go with shovel guy
yeah shovel guy yeah yeah so that's the
thing is it's be more specific do the
crime same thing with the looting i
don't think anyone is ever charged with
looting they're charged with property
theft right that's a good point so just
go to the crime
or if you can do the time that was you
know what that was very perceptive hey
you know that's why i'm here
all right to the back of the
dr siegel you deal with uh you deal with
you know deal with sex offenders uh
although i am your patient
the idea
i don't even know what that means the
idea that like the terms have to be less
stigmatizing there is is there a purpose
to that in any
in your mind well jimmy it really hit it
from the beginning which is we're
identifying with the criminal instead of
with the victim yeah so if we start with
smash and go it's going to be grab and
go and what about stop and frisk what
happens to that that already was
politically incorrect and and the point
about rapists i agree with i mean we're
really worrying about sex offenders they
should have a sign that says i violated
your humanity i attacked you i destroyed
you physically and psychologically but
i've reformed so you can't call me that
anymore yeah that's a big sign though
all right that won't fit no that's true
and by the way one more thing yeah you
read stephen king's the mr mercedes
right the mercedes killer that it was
clear in those days i think this this
criminal actually even patterned himself
after that if you drive into a crowd
yeah and kill people it's not a crash if
we start calling that kind of mass
murder crashing because the person is
black we're done we're done yeah degan
you get the last word and make it
southern look at this
talk about sweet tea yeah i don't have a
word i just say
um but i
i i pay attention to language if someone
tells me that don't call me this or that
word is offensive to me i will avoid it
but i'm not sure that the professional
thieves who are stealing from these
stores really care about being called
looters or not i think that's probably
not in their top ten of concerns and
actually looting makes it sound kind of
spur of the moment and whimsical yeah
this was planned right instead of being
a professional crook
i don't mind being called a redneck you
know back in the day that would apply
not from an agricultural perspective but
from you know
hickeys and like love suction on my neck
by the way
fashion lizard another thing i wouldn't
use that though because it's offensive
to lizards is that true and reptiles and
snakes and even turtles you know i i
think we got to button this thing up but
i think kovid really did kill another
thing and that was hickeys yeah
absolutely but in my defense we can't
all shop at forever 51.
you actually undershot my age
i'm gonna get out of this segment before
uh
before i really get audited hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else